ces ukrainiens ont pris toutes les
affaires qu'ils pouvaient ils ont fui la
ville de severodonezk et les
bombardements russes
désormais akram à tort ce qu'à 100 km à
l'ouest ils sont désormais en sécurité
mais pour combien de temps avec sa fille
de deux mois volodymyr ne veut prendre
aucun risque
c'est plus sûr ici qu'ailleurs dans la
province de donetsk l'on ferait mieux de
partir
les russes gagnent du terrain ils ne
s'arrêteront pas c'est pourquoi me
devront fuir au plus loin
témoin de la violence des combats la
ville de robinet en périphérie de
severodonetsk désormais complètement
détruite mais les habitants qui sont
restés ne baisse pas les bras là-bas la
solidarité s'organise distribution d'eau
de nourriture ou encore de médicaments
ils survivent comme ils le peuvent dans
des abris anti bombes
il n'y a plus d'électricité plus d'eau
ou de gaz dans la ville
les gars se réveille à 5h30 du matin
ils apportent de l'eau
il coupe du bois et il nous cuisiner des
plats sur le feu
selon le gouverneur de lougansk
severodonezk ville stratégique du
dombass est proche de tomber
70% de la ville est sous contrôle russe
sous le contrôle de l'armée russe
10 à 15 % correspondent à une sorte de
zone grise et le reste est tenu par nos
soldats
selon lui 15 mille civils seraient
encore dans la ville pour l'heure il est
impossible de les évacuer